to
driver is
showing some obscure driving possibly
intoxicated
currently doing 45 miles an hour
zone through here is 25. oh
subject just hit the curb
correction speed limit is 15.
i'm about three quarters of a mile into
the arches just before the gate
you want to place your vehicle in the
park and go ahead and turn it off for me
no park oh if it isn't perfect okay turn
off your engine go ahead and set your
keys on the dash for me all right
what's your guys's names yeah i'm brian
gabby brian okay
what's going on how come you're crying
i'm sorry we've just been fighting this
morning
some personal issues it was a long day
we were camping yesterday and camping
got
supplies and stuff i'm sorry i'm sorry i
hit the
bump there
i was distracting him from driving i'm
sorry can i get you to step out of the
vehicle for me man yeah
just hang tight right there um do you
mind if i take your keys and just put
them on your hood
i'm so sorry oh no you're fine
i'm gonna go ahead and close your hair
okay
yeah i don't know it's just
some days
a really bad ocd and i just
i was just cleaning and creating a bag
of them before and i was apologizing to
him and saying i'm sorry that i'm so
mean because sometimes i have ocd and
sometimes i just get really frustrated
i'm not like me and poor time i just
like
i mean i guess
my vibe is like i've been here like in a
bad mood and i was just saying i'm sorry
if i'm in a bad mood i'm just really
stressed i had so much work i was doing
on my computer this morning what do you
do for a living
um well i i hate for getting an organic
juice bar but i just hit my job
okay i was a nutritionist that's right
that was my job and i just um quit my
job to travel across the country and i'm
trying to start a blog
stuff so i've been building my website
so i've just been really stressed but
he doesn't really believe that i could
do any of it so that's kind of been like
uh
i don't know he's like
down there i don't know we just been
fighting all morning and
and he wouldn't let me in the car before
why wouldn't you let you in the car
because you're
this is a rough morning
well why don't we do this
why don't i sit you down in the back
seat of my car you're not in any trouble
okay i'm not gonna be putting handcuffs
on you
you obviously don't have any weapons i'm
gonna get you into the air conditioning
let you take a breath relax a little bit
and then i'll come back and talk to you
in a few minutes okay okay all righty
like i said you're not in any trouble
so just go ahead and take a seat
yeah i just spoke to her yeah so you
want to do me a favor let's go ahead and
get you to step out of the vehicle
alrighty
come on over here
you're not in any trouble right now
so tell me what's going on
we see this gets worked up sometimes and
i try and really distance myself from
her so like i i locked the car and i
walked away from her what happened this
morning is that she's trying to start up
like his own little website vlog and
everything so like every time
we really had a nice morning and if
anything but um she just got worked up
as you're trying to get going and get
her day going because you want to go um
okay
you want to tell me about those
scratches on your face she had himself
on her hand that's why i was pushing her
away is because i
see she wanted i like the keys so i
could walk away i said let's just take a
breather and let's not you know go
anywhere let's just calm down for a
minute
and then she had her phone was trying to
get the treats
i know i shouldn't push but i was just
trying to push her away to go let's
let's just take a minute step back and
breathe and we see it she got me up here
can i see your hand
oh you got a mark right here
oh that's from a wire that's on a wire
yeah you want to tell me about hitting
that curve
hitting the curve with her grabbing the
wheel did she grab the wheel yeah she
said i can't leave her again pulled over
here
what about the speed did she take over
the
pedal on you if i was going fast i'm
sorry i know it's probably just the
moment of i'm still shaking now you
generally seen the light splashing up
and then the urban grip and the wheel
and so if i sped up i'm sorry about that
or if i was sweating beforehand i'm
sorry about that
quite a bit to catch up to you so
yeah i'm sorry about that we're just
going into the the park again to get
water because we have a 6 gallon water
container to fill up so we're just
grabbing wonderful height and we're just
i was trying to
keep everything calm and quiet because
they're just playing still to go for a
hike
i'm
do me a favor do you want to go ahead
and just take a seat right over here on
the curb for me and if i was speeding
i'm sorry you don't have anything in my
pocket or anything like that
nope just the wallet all right and then
do you mind lifting your shirt so i can
check the waistband i gotta turn around
for me real quick perfect nothing i just
i just want to make sure that's all man
go ahead do me a favor take a seat all
right
oh do you have your id on you in the car
if you want to come with me we'll just
do
l-a-u-n
l-a-u-n b-r-i-e
d-r-i-e yep laundry
okay what's your data builders brian
i'll say crisscross applesauce can i
just sit in the shades through the mold
um
it's okay i'll give you some [ __ ] sound
good
all right just hang tight for me
so229 i need a 29 name and date of birth
first name brian layman spelling's last
name laundry
lima alpha uniform november delta romeo
india
is
it's gonna be out of florida
don't worry
or what
you were hitting him
did you already tell him all this
i didn't get that far into it she was
she was hyperventilating
they don't drink but at the point where
you lit them up you don't make sure
anything she started hitting me yeah i
was yelling at him and then when you
turned it like that i like kind of
[ __ ] his arm
hit the curb
yeah i'm sorry i'm really bad it was
gabby
try to meditate stuff
but you tend to have a lot of anxiety
and stress you have a lot of excitement
and what's his name is it brian is he
usually pretty patient with you
but i guess it just makes me sad i know
that he kept like it's frustrating
way of taking my anxiety and bringing it
down
but my ex-wife
especially my ex-wife
i'm just sharing i know it's a little
personal to help you understand
we would feed off each other's anxiety
and spiral you know what i mean and it
doesn't matter how much i loved her
it may be a bad for your soul just
saying i'm not telling you to do with
your life but if you know you have
anxiety look at the
look at the situations you can get in
you know what i mean
and we're not here to be mean to you or
anything well you know they never
there's a first time and then it usually
let's just we'll go see what brian's
saying but
i think you've heard everything now
quick question you said you were hitting
him in the arm did you grab the steering
wheel no i didn't you did not touch the
steering wheel
only for like a second because i just
saw the lights come on and it was more
just like you're an idiot like you know
but did you grab the steering wheel and
like swerve or anything like that no no
no no
at all
i'm gonna go ahead and close this door
again you have enough air back here or
do you want me to kick it up some more
do you have any water
i will see if i can find something okay
don't worry thank you
you wouldn't happen to have any water
would you
i might
on her too we're just trying to figure
out what all happened and i know you
probably already told your story
this officer is probably gonna be the
one handling the whole case you want to
you want to listen to what he has to say
and yeah and then you tell him and tell
him what happened
so we don't mind start at the beginning
for me
started beginning um well
i don't go too far back but we've been
in uh beyond land for the past week or
so traveling around and the flies here
like pretty intense so the flies have
definitely been getting to her and then
my feet are dirty and everything so i
think that our little squabble started
because we're hanging out of the coffee
shop and when we got back to the vendors
and dirt and stuff the van and i moved
our food around this was a little bit so
you know so
she gets a little we take over
sorry about that do you need any water
that's okay it's hot actually i was
telling you you're going to get one
because you ran out but it's okay
i don't like classic bottles okay
um
but we just had a little disagreement
there and this game was just she was
getting a little worked up and i was
saying no it's okay thank you so much
that's good
um
so it was just more disappearing than i
just wanted what was the disagreement
about it was it was i wouldn't even call
it this game it was just that i'm dirty
and i can't change being dirty like i
got 30 feet i got stand in my flip-flops
and stuff like that um
it was everywhere at the coffee shop for
so long because we were there from nine
to three so yeah there's a few little
little things little just little
relationships
in a relationship i've been married for
over five years now there's a lot of
little things right yeah um
we really it wasn't
we weren't physical before the point
where i said all right let's let's just
take a breather and
like walk away for a minute i'll lock
the van up and i'll go for a walk this
way and you can go walk that way on the
block you know there's a moon
i've always called moon flowers right
yeah nice areas if you go either way
it's all shaded so let's go for a little
walk and breathe we'll come back it's
pretty happy with that
um
but if she's
i said i'm not upset that they're in the
machine guys it was worked up and she
had a phone in her hand and the keys and
everything and she wanted another
i don't have my phone i don't really i
don't have a phone so she goes off
without me
all right
i'm on my own so uh i was saying let's
just go for walking shoes trying to get
the keys for me so i'm just going to
sleep back up back up and it doesn't
hit me and i i did didn't get i don't
want to push you but i didn't get bit i
didn't get overly physical i was just
trying to keep her away and not get hit
and then i got really loud and like
that's like driving his attention where
i was going
you know back up get away just give me
okay so i said you pushed her to create
some distance obviously right what
happened after that what got
what got the scratches on your eye the
phone the phone so you pushed her and
she hit you she was it
i wasn't it wasn't like a push and she
jumped on me she was she's already
she was already
i don't wanna she's already swinging and
i was like
do you mind lifting up your right sleeve
for me i'm curious about something
i suppose fingernails but i'm not
complaining i'm not complaining about it
is it bruised or tender or anything like
that
okay i'm fine and i look good
i hope she doesn't have too many
complaints about me
i'm just uh
you know
i feel bad i didn't get so public i was
just trying to be loud to this and this
is
you know all right try to make her calm
down be like look everyone's watching
good things
do you take any medications or anything
like that
you don't take any medications or
anything like that
are you normally this kind of like piper
do i see that my heartbeat whenever the
lights flash on it it gets your heart
rate up if i see my trust me it does me
too and i'm the one
it gets me going a little probably hey
buddy whenever somebody wants it so
all right
real fast can i get your first name
gabrielle how do you spell that
your last name
b-e-t
o-o-p
you guys both live in florida right
or that's where you guys come from
right now
but that's where you have it out of
curling
i need a
lima
oscar
it's gonna be florida
we're just kind of hanging tight for me
um
what was the determinant
so i was like let's let's do it better
and it's got a big band about a big
stinky bandage
but uh
i said let's try and do a little better
i mean it's been great so far for sure
but here we're going over to portland
and i don't know if you
i'm from california originally oh yeah
so and part of my job i dealt with
employees that were from all across the
united states and washington
oregon california nevada everything you
can think of on your website i know most
of whom yeah
give it to us it's worldwide
opportunities on organic farming so it's
like a volunteer work away technical
so that's our goal once we get over to
uh washington
we'll do that from washington then down
to oregon
california
what part of california
oh
and i recorded it you want me to tell
you what he said real quick do you mind
hanging with him for a
he
minute
that he never saw the male strike the
female he saw
the male trying to lock her out of the
vehicle she even told us that he was
trying to lock her out told her to go
take a walk
so that she was trying to get in she
eventually couldn't get in and actually
caught her way in through the driver's
door he said i don't understand why
she's doing that well i think it's
because of his only door that wasn't
locked that she can get through
she's trying to get it over him
he's trying to disengage from her i
guess he hung her backpack on the back
probably so she'd have her [ __ ] so that
he didn't have to engage with her
everything she's saying is
same thing i haven't heard what he said
but that's what he said that's also what
the witness is saying the witness says i
never saw him hit her i saw him
shove her but i couldn't tell if it was
an aggression against her or a defense
against her as far as her
you know
being the aggressor
so at this point
from what unless the guy's screaming
that he needs to go to jail and did
something to this girl it sounds to me
is the primary aggressor
now the problem with her being the
primary aggressor
is in an incidence of domestic assault
being a male or being a female
we shall rest now
that doesn't necessarily mean they have
to go to jail we can do a citation if it
meets one of three criterion which one
of them is that we can ensure that
they're
not going to
further risk each other's safety but the
problem with that is they live in the
same vehicle
that's what i was going to say the other
part of it is there was an injury to
the victim which is him right and i'm
getting conflicting stories about why
they hit the curb up here
what did he say why hit the curb well
i've watched this is what i saw first
saw him across the double yellow i was
doing 42 miles an hour
i was i don't know probably two car
lengths behind him
tapping my whales at him trying to get
his attention they knew i was behind him
and then after he crossed the double
yellow he merged over into the right
lane and then out of nowhere just boom
so did he tell you why he said that she
grabbed the wheel and turned it real
hard she said that she was hitting him
in the arm
so sounds legit i mean
i'm sure if i'm driving and my arm's on
the wheel and i'm getting hit in the arm
i'm probably
pulling out the wheel yeah and i'm sure
it was a little both and usually the
truth is somewhere between he's probably
trying not to
say that he hit her because he probably
doesn't want her charged with assault
yeah i must consult and he probably
would rather say she pulled the wheel
then hit him yeah
so
unfortunately for her
she
we cannot just because he's bigger and
stronger even if he's not one of the
best charges if we can't treat this
differently than if it was a male on
female violence
and we're going to have to charge her
and
we can do a citation if there's some
arrangement that can be made to separate
them and then we have to let them know
that there's no contact order in effect
and we had to let him know the only way
to drop is going to the police
department during business hours and
fill out a waiver which by the way
what's today today thursday
so it won't be until tomorrow
i know there until noon i think yeah
which i'm sure he's gonna want to drop
it
well the other part of it is they said
that they're on uh
they've been on four or five months that
they've been living out of this band
together
well this is really bad news let's talk
to him first
ryan yeah
unfortunately in the state of utah
we don't have discretion on some things
like for example
for speeding and i want to give you a
warning i can do that because it's under
her in class a it's a class b or under
if i want to give you more than all
kinds of stuff i can but there's a few
things i can't
when i say i please i'm not trying to
trade
one of the things that the state
legislature doesn't give us discretion
on is charges when it comes to a
domestic assault
and it sounds like you guys are living
together
so
you meet the statute for domestic
partners
and you do have injury
and both an independent witness probably
the next one we're going to talk to as
well which we haven't talked to yet but
one the ones we did talk to
and your own
companion
have made it clear that she was the
primary aggressor
and that she was striking you in the ufc
the witness did not see a striker
so at this point you're the victim of a
domestic assault
even if you didn't want to pursue this
we don't have a choice the best thing we
could do
to not
so lots of we have to charge it doesn't
say we have to put her in jail
okay but it also says we have to
separate our contact order
and we have to put our job if we cannot
separate
and there's little problem here is
you've got a lot of floor to lifting the
pad together how are reasons to separate
them
no i don't want to take this small 20
what issue
22 year old wheels
yeah you could definitely defend
yourself against but at the same time we
can't say because you're a male as
you're the female we can't treat this
different than the view of the bell
hitting her
without treating the same way
but she's kind of a tough spot so unless
you have an idea about how she did not
go to jail and be separated
somewhere she could stay tomorrow if you
want to it's up to you you cannot go to
jail
you can't because you don't have a
charge
if you wanted to get with her again
tomorrow
you can go to the police department fill
out a waiver to drop the no contact door
so you guys can still get again but
she's gonna have a court date online
i had to get so public um
but
so i just want to get like the checklist
of things i got to do to get rid of this
association
well she'll get a paper with a court
date how do i get rid of it
well the court date has to be attended
in order for them to decide whether they
need to continue to drop it the first is
an initial appearance to say are you who
we think you are yes
do you understand the charges from
brought against yes or no yes no the
answer
uh do you have an attorney yes no do you
need one
and then
the first court appearance
because she has to attend which
thankfully for you guys is going to be
online
so if you're out of town
here's the thing if you're out of town
and she doesn't come into reporter
parents online driver's license
so she needs
well
there's automatically right now there's
something called a no contact in place
yeah at this point we're gonna tell
tomorrow if you wish to drop it you have
to go to the 217 east center street
i've got all the pictures and you have
to actually get
so tomorrow they open to eight you can
go to the police department you can call
the waiver they can remove it then you
can say hey babe where you at let me
kick you up
pick her up now we're hoping not to put
her in jail but she doesn't have
somewhere to go tonight
to be separate from you
so tell me this
do you guys have enough money for like a
hotel room or anything like that what we
could do
is we'd cite her for this and then i'd
give her a ride over to whatever hotel
you guys is choosing pick up on them and
you have to know
on your way to go pick her up you stop
over there at the pd sign the paperwork
that they requested and then you can go
pick her up quite literally
unless you know someone else in town
that's a premise
yeah
you know unfortunately not i don't but i
guess that
yeah
i don't want her to go to jail
well
if she goes to jail it's like uh
that goes down somewhere instead of
we're going to tell right if you did a
citation
and then if they
if they don't convict her then it would
just show that it was dismissed it was
going to show up in a criminal history
but she was found guilty to show up here
but the charge the charge itself will
show up on her history until she gets
response
now even if we give her a ticket
we're still gonna take a fingerprint
either way it's gonna show up
there's no way around the class a or is
this class b this is class b they do
require fingerprints yeah okay so the
other part is if you contact her or she
contacts you she could be charged with a
classmate
which is a little bit different but it
doesn't help if you were to contact her
and she responds to you then she could
get a new charge
no contact doesn't restrict
i'm just trying to figure out a way
you don't know anyone in town you guys
figure out why no i don't know anyone in
town if she went
i don't think sleepy will take it to see
the aggressor
no there's a window shelter i'm curious
to delegate all right does she have a
good driver's license
then you're trying to be homeless for
the night
man i can't talk to her at all
and i've got to do the thing so i can't
go camping you can tell her what it is
that she needs to do to get
to get through all this and then let her
know what the line is here here's the
problem though if we take you up to
delicate arts you're going to be hoping
it from delicate arch
all the way down to moab center street
so that you can add that paperwork
because if you're not there by noon
tomorrow you're going to be looking at
monday morning so early on friday
yeah
you'd be looking at monday morning
before you could actually see the right
yeah
and again we're not trying to make your
life right now this is written
to domestic assault not everybody's the
same this is different than normal but
we have to do everything
we can
i'll see if they'll if they'll take you
there
and they'll help you tomorrow and you're
like a block and a half away from the
people well cnc will take him because
they took they actually put up actually
they didn't take a guy but they got a
hotel for a guy last time yeah i'll do
that we might get you on top
now what she does i might be sleeping
outside on a sleeping bag no no i don't
know
i think so i'm just saying i think we'll
get you a hotel
if you want her to have a man
yes this is officer robinson city police
department how are you doing this
afternoon
oh not too bad not too bad so i just did
a domestic and
the male is going to be our victim is
there any way that you can help us set
him up with a place to stay tonight
okay
10.99 yeah
yes please
thank
you right
so
the after hours guy isn't there at their
office right now
he's going to run from his house over
there and we're going to get you all
lined up
don't worry about it this is the point
that they wait on so don't
don't feel like you are making anybody
do anything extra
so
we're trying to make this as easy as
possible
or anything like that well i really
really and i know how rough this stuff
can be like i said
oh it's my anxiety and sometimes that's
why i just that's why i'm like i gotta
just i gotta walk away i gotta breathe
just i'm looking back as far as you can
you know but
i'm not gonna try to sit here and give
you life
you've been on this road almost as long
as what i have there's nothing i can
tell you that's gonna
really make a difference but at the end
of the day
i'm sorry that all this is happening i'm
sorry that it went to business no no i'm
sorry
could i get my key and make like a
little bag maybe again driving somewhere
yeah it's all right would you mind
watching for me yeah yeah just if you
don't mind doing it from over here we
don't want you to get hit in the road
i don't have anyone saying he actually
punched through basically it sounds like
he was shoving
in a manner that was probably more
consistent with trying to eventually
demand space for you
so
if the tables were turned and he was
beating on you and you were shoving him
of course we're going to look at it like
oh of course he's defending himself
but we're kind of looking at the same
way with him
there you
go law doesn't say hey officer crowd off
robbins you can treat people different
based on gender since we can't
because it makes no sense
hey how's it going
oh that that's fine i'm still going to
be here for a few minutes dealing with
this so we have
almost as much time as you need
so
his name's going to be brian b-r-i-a-n
last name laundry is l-a-u-n-d-r-i-e
and laundry
yeah well it's not why it's ie at the
end
yes
so they were at one at moon flower the
organic grocery store down the street
with you guys and
they got into a heated argument both of
them are saying it was over petty stuff
um
he told her to take a walk so that she
could cool off
she refused
broke into the car after he walked her
out of it
she started trying to slap and scratch
him he pushed her away
they both got in the vehicle took off
and i found him out here
no
well we are charging her with
domestic assault
so
there's gonna be a protection order set
in place between the two of them until
he's able to get over to the pd tomorrow
because he doesn't want to pursue it but
i don't have a choice in this i'm sure
you are well aware
so he's going to be wanting to go over
to the pd first thing tomorrow morning
as they open up to get the protective
order removed
but that doesn't fix tonight
sorry about that go ahead
yes they both have florida licenses
of course
right
well the other part of it is i don't
we don't think it's very likely but with
her as the
uh suspect in this
would you be able to put her up for the
night
okay
i figured i figured i just i had to make
sure i at least asked
it's better safe than sorry so i didn't
know if that would make your life any
easier or any tougher one so
good
awesome and if you if it's easier for
you to just send me a text to the
location
that works just as
fine right it sounds like fun thank you
what was your what did you say your name
was again peter phillip phil okay
all right
hey brian
can i take two minutes of your time real
quick back here
so
because there was an assault that took
place and you're
obviously showing signs of the strikes
do you mind if i take pictures of the
injuries that you sustain i know it's
not super severe i mean you want me to
call it i mean i could call you a mess
if you want me to you don't seem like
you want to go that far if you don't
take a photo you can take a photo of it
yeah i need to take pictures for my
evidence because otherwise it's going to
be
you're safe let's say my say in the
courts going
so i have to do this part of it already
so it's just going to be a couple of
pictures
is
where are we going to
i was trying to
build some consistency between the
stories
and then let me see your hand is
i know you said this is from a wire but
i'm going to take a picture of it just
in case i'll document that
that you're saying that's from a wire
not from her it's just i wouldn't
document everything
if you have anything on the other arm on
your back chest anything like that let
me get your neck real quick as well if
you want to kind of tilt your head off
to the right and look out this way
and then
this is just for crossings you mind
lifting your shirt for me
we can go back here if you want some
privacy
i just i want it like i said i want to
do a very thorough job i want to make
sure that you don't have any additional
injuries
people that can help with hotel rooms
and stuff like that i have at the office
i'm just playing home type they've got a
couple people trying to get all lined up
because certain people have access to
the corporate card he doesn't
so we're trying to get everything lined
up this is going to take us a few
minutes to get that lined up get more
uh excited and stuff like that like i
said we're gonna be handing out a piece
of paper that has a port summit
and stuff like that and she'll be able
to give you all that information
okay
them tonight
there's
no choice in the matter
so
okay
okay
um
try it
right
um
she went to smack him
well he's got a swollen
right eye
scratches
so we're going to go find it
was it intent and attempt or intent or
right
is
right
this is a very very important question
how you answer this question is going to
determine what happens next but the only
person who can answer this question is
you
think very hard before you answer the
question do not quickly answer think
very hard
when
you
slapped him those times
were you attempting to cause him
physical pain or physical impairment was
that what you were attempting to do to
him
what were you what were you attempting
to do
what was the reason behind the slapping
and stuff
what was what was it you were attempting
to accomplish
by slapping i was trying to get home
well it doesn't sound to me like she
attempted the
injury it's your call
this is 100 your goal i support you
either way i'll let you get back to your
parents okay
he said that she was striking him in the
air
he said she was and that's what caused
him to hit the curve
she said that she got hurt i might have
these two problems
so assault is an attempt with unlawful
portrait violence to bother the injury
to another
code for bodily injury the definition
says bodily injury is affliction of pain
or physical impairment or illness
so you can go
this now i'm just gonna i'm gonna be i'm
recording and society and the judges and
everyone can judge me for this i am
looking at a 110 pound female
and her fiance who have no means to be
separated he doesn't want to pursue it
she's not a threat to him more than
slight abrasions from her fingernails
i
i don't care if
we use the actual letter of the law to
to not charge but i also don't care
because it literally does possibly make
perfect sense to go
full on domestic assault and do the
whole thing
this is uh your opportunity to make the
decision let's
thank you
well
i'm it's six one way half dozen yeah
that's up to you i mean it's a headache
whether i go left or it's a headache
whether i go right another option is to
not charge them but separate from the
knife
if they find themselves together again
what is it to you you separated them you
provide it for his safety if he doesn't
have enough sense to stay away and you
got him separated it's on him
you can separate him and say don't
don't let us go off till tomorrow
if if they don't let it go off and we
hear about it
we'll hear about it they're camping in
the park tonight
and if there's some fighting going on
you already was mr nice guy you already
gave him a chance what you can't do by
law is separate someone and say if we
hear from you again we're gonna mess
with you because then if one of them
really needs help they may not call
police and get help the law says you
cannot literally you may not say
we get more problems with you guys
tonight one of you is known as if you
can't threaten like that right it's true
because it stops you want to call the
things
that make sense all right so go full
or
nothing or in between and separate them
and kind of give them the nod the wink
like hey you
it's up to you i'm going to go handle
that
you got very capable help with you here
and i trust you
i will
all righty man so we're still gonna be
going through i do need some things from
you do you mind if i get a picture of
your driver's license
yeah of course i was thinking it wasn't
part of that
this is me
oh another man is here
he said that this is still your mailing
address
right away
all right and then
oh yeah no problem have a good day
all right there we go can i get your
phone number
okay do you have any problems with me
taking a picture of it i have to have
ids and stuff like that for my
investigation
here
so
this is what i'm gonna do
i've decided i am not going to cite you
for
domestic violence
battery okay
it was only going to be a
class b misdemeanor
however
the domestic violence portion of it
enhances it
makes like a major pain in the butt
especially your 22 right
so i'm choosing not to cite you today so
you are not going to be charged with
anything
all right but this is what i do have to
do
i am separating between you tonight
okay
i want you guys both to be
tonight away from each other relax
breathe
crying because there's no reason to be
crying now okay
this is
i understand that this can feel like
it's a nightmare
but you're coming out as the
golden flower on top of it okay
so
you're going to be taking the band
tonight
and you're going to go somewhere else
i am going to get him lined up for the
hotel room tonight
i want you guys to stay away from each
other
for both of you guys to see me
from what you told me and what he told
me you guys have a bunch of little
things that are building up building up
building up and finally the little
string that you guys were tight walking
on earlier tonight does that sound about
right
so i just want everybody to
breathe
get the chance away from each other
go eat a meal talk to your parents
whatever it is you gotta do here
just told me something
so
like i said
that's what i'm going to be doing
tonight
hold on
this is officer robbins
up
perfect
so
awesome thank you phil is this your cell
phone that i called
okay
okay
well go ahead and save my number into
that phone and i'll save your number
this number into my phone that way i can
contact the
i'm
on duty after hours
person
so because i literally had to google it
so
perfect
thank you phil i appreciate your time
all right
so
i've got him a hotel room tonight
so here in just a minute i have to keep
you guys separated
for right now don't contact each other
don't wave at um okay do you want me to
say anything to him because i can do
that for you
you want me to let him know that you
love him and that you'll see him
tomorrow and stuff like that
definitely good oh he's bad about that
too yeah okay i'll make sure that he has
a phone charger okay
and if i have anything else please keep
your cell phone on so i can call you
okay
it's all right
all right so just kind of sit tight for
me real fast going to talk tomorrow
all right brian a couple things
a couple things a couple things one i
got your hotel room
thank you thank you
outside
number two and this is probably the
biggest one
she claims that she did not have intent
to hurt you
when she was slapping at you
so technically speaking it does not fit
the letter of the code
so
i am not going to be charging her with
db
exactly
so
this is what i am going to do now
i'm not gonna release you guys together
i want you guys to stay away from each
other tonight
okay
she's agreed to it
take some time for yourselves
you guys both have the exact same story
as to what led up to the incident so
taking some time tonight specifically
taking tonight away from each other is
going to be the major breaker in all of
this i think that'll help you guys
especially tomorrow when you guys meet
up
so she does have a couple of messages
for you
one she says she loves you
she's looking forward to seeing you
tomorrow
two don't forget a cell phone
yeah again he watched me fumble around
the entire three laptop i'm trying to
find one
the other thing is i don't want you guys
to contact each other
no okay
when you said that
she gonna text me or whatever i was
gonna send a message so please don't
message me
but yeah but tonight don't do anything
yeah but when she's passing on her love
and sound at night and stuff like that
all that interview stuff that i do to my
wife too okay
so i appreciate it just just
so don't
just try to not contact each other
unless like i said earth chattering
something happens you guys have to jump
in the car right now and drive back to
florida because something happened here
that kind of circumstances
exactly other than that just
have meals about yourself protect your
breath you're gonna be in a hotel room
watching tv it's probably been a few
months since you actually got to set
down relax it's american origin and
watch tv
so take some time
take a shower you got to change your
clothes you got some tony's in there
right all right good good because
they're going to have everything that
you need
all right our main concern is make sure
that you have a cell phone card so you
guys can knock them out okay i really
appreciate it
i am going to walk her over here to the
car
okay
and if you'll just go stand over here in
front of his pickup real quick we'll get
her out of here
all righty gabrielle you want to step
out for me
as you can see i have keys in my hand
which is good okay
so
something that i do that i emphasize to
him and i don't know if i emphasize to
you or not
don't text each other tonight he wants
to pass on the same message you passed
to him i'm really looking forward to
talking to you again but i told him and
you unless there's earth-shattering
emergency news
don't text tonight okay even with the
good nights i love you he's saying
goodnight now he's saying he loves you
now and you guys can talk tomorrow
morning okay he's going to go to the
hotel i'm going to give you the keys to
the van
which will happen
alrighty
so here's that i'm giving him a ride
over to the hotel
okay
so everything's gonna be okay will it be
a hard drive for me to get him in the
morning
i'm just curious i'm not gonna tell you
where he's gonna be at tonight like i
said i i want you guys to be separated
but i can tell you this i just don't
usually drive the van so i just want to
make sure it's not like far away no not
at all
it's
it's basically from here to my flower
okay it's not far at all
so
let's get you in the van let's get you
on your way alrighty
you want that gatorade by the way
you got enough water
also something i want you to know here
stand over here real quick real fast
forward
if you go over to city market they have
a list of places where you can get
yourself a shower for like four or five
bucks something like that but pretty
cheap place where you can shower
decompress de-stress a little bit
alrighty um yeah i just showered
yesterday at one of those well you
didn't have today happen yesterday so
i it does my wife wanders when she gets
stressed out it's like get in the shower
come on
go take a shower relax
take some time for yourself and like i
said don't text each other tonight text
each other tomorrow morning after your
eyes open up and you're fully awake had
your coffee or your morning routine okay
you ready
uh my door is open just climb in the
back seat for me
yeah you can put your backpack back
there too
sorry about that approach i don't know
what the hell he's doing
it's all right it was it was an
interesting poland so
thanksgiving
daniel by the way if i didn't formally
introduce myself i'm daniel i'm 59 so if
you hear that you know you're not going
to
hurry ryan see i hear you guys all the
time
it was nice meeting you guys
heck yeah dude i got my own phone hooked
up to this thing
hey man it's not too hard to go a few
hours without having anything
interesting happen or anything to
get the old blood pumping real good you
know what i mean
so
i stuck my hands up because i didn't
want to scare you when pulled over oh no
no you're
that wasn't a traditional stop to say
the least so don't feel bad
so2t9
didn't already know
she did want to pass on her good nights
and love zoos and stuff like that okay
and she understands that i don't i
didn't tell her where you're staying
because like i said i'm trying to
keep you guys away from each other for
tonight
i just told you that you were going to a
hotel
okay
so um
like i said it's my request
not legally obligated to hold to it
but i want you guys to
take some time away from each other
because it will make
a world of difference
oh you're not in any trouble you got
handcuffs on
i didn't tell you that i'm taking you to
jail no i told you i'm taken to the
hotel so
like i said my main concern i told her
to go take a shower like i told you to
because
she seems a lot like my wife
and things that really works for my wife
is when she gets stressed out to go take
a long hot shower so i gave her a place
to go where she can get a hotel room or
not a hotel room but um
get a shower tonight for like four or
five bucks really cheap
so
no problem
well i've got quite a few
like i said my wife has really really
bad bad anxiety and she takes medication
for it daily
and sometimes it's just not enough
sometimes it builds up and it happens
i mean i think
well i will say this
when my wife got put onto medication
within a week i saw a complete
turnaround in her attitude her
demeanor
i mean she wasn't nearly as aggressive
or angry or anything like that it was
it was a considerable difference in her
day-to-day life it made her quality of
life better even you know what i mean
and it's made my quality of life a lot
better too because i don't have her
being as stressed i know that i
five and a half years of marriage i know
it's not very long but at the same time
you learn a lot in the first five years
how long you guys been together um
we've known each other since the start
of high school
i used to i used to drive a truck
i used to be a commercial motor vehicle
driver you know the big trucks oh yeah
and i took my wife with me and we would
easily spend a couple months on end
without going home or anything like that
being cooped up in a
little 8x8 cage
is what i called it because
you didn't have any time to yourself so
to speak you didn't have time to
you know you're going through arizona
you can't just turn off the road and go
see the grand canyon or anything like
that
well that was one of the major
advantages of having her with me was i
could say hey i'm hungry can you get me
something she she was able because i was
driving and she wasn't she was able to
go back get into the cooler
make us lunch or whatever you know
so
there was that as an advantage
if everything
is
i think you're wrong
i've lived here i'm just sure i have two
years living out here but my
grandfather's lived out here for like 40
so i've been through here a couple of
times
but you know growing up in california
have you ever been there
yeah yeah
um
i love the i love driving the one i
absolutely love it but
we're really looking forward to getting
back there
it's beautiful here but
those are just definitely
coming from like new york and being on
the appalachian trail yeah trees and
waterfalls when you come here and it
started well if you hit the one if you
take the 80 across
to get into california takes you up over
donner pass and into sacramento
it's not
any different at all but you said you're
gonna be going up to oregon to see
her grandmother or her grandmother's
friend
so you'll be probably excuse me you'll
probably be coming down the five
you won't be able to tell the difference
between california and oregon up there
yeah except for the fact that there's
going to be a sign that says welcome to
california
but at the same time since you're going
to be coming from the east side of
oregon you're going to be driving
through oregon and going there's no
difference between utah
it's actually desert in the south
east corner of oregon it's a lot of high
desert atmosphere like what this is it's
not the red rock or anything like that
but
it's just there's nothing out there for
120 miles it
what was your seems like
i mean like
parks
look if you don't hit sequoia national
park
while you're in california you are doing
yourself a disservice
if you don't go and see yosemite
while you're in california you're doing
yourself
just
i regret that
it's like coming to utah you come here
with the intention of one or two days
and then it turns into a week you're
like well what happened to the time yeah
trust me i get it
building the band with supreme just
because the nissan century
if you're trying to camp out somewhere
if you can't like sleep over walmart
type situations
is
but yeah
sorry my radio was going off
but uh no
sequoia national park there is nothing
like it gotta see the general sherman
tree
you gotta go and see uh
moral rock and climb to the top you like
hiking it's about a mile and a half hike
well worth it
gotta do it um
it's really really cheap for their tent
sites up there
do you have a uh national park service
pass
perfect
um the dream is ninety dollars or no
eighty dollars once it's
well the other thing of it is
with that drive if you go through
yosemite
you'll drop down into fresno and then
you'll turn off to go to
uh kings canyon national park
if you drive through kings canyon
national park the road literally takes
you through to sequoia national park
and the king's canyon is actually
bigger than the grand canyon
yeah i'm dead serious i'm dead serious
and it is a sight to behold i'll tell
you what
and then yeah it takes you straight into
sequoias and then when you get into um
i think they call it this
i think they call it sierra highway
still up there
but you'll take that down and you'll pop
up into a town called three rivers it's
where i'm from
yep
uh my house i think the furthest i lived
away from it was like 12 miles from the
entrance
i just hope you don't get motion
sickness because it's
it's
i think i counted it out to like 32
hairpin turns and it's about 25 miles an
hour the whole way up and down
it's very very slow it takes about an
hour to travel at 30 miles 35 miles
whatever it is
but it's worth it
all right we're here
i didn't have to
file anything
we're gonna come in here we're gonna
talk
tyson yep
officer robin's phil called for me he
did yes
this is brian laundry all right so he's
gonna get you all set up with your hotel
room
and he's going to take care of it from
here all right all right and like i said
just remember my requests
i think it'll make a big difference in
you guys the next couple weeks
i really appreciate it thank you so much
for everything no problem it's nice to
meet you ryan nice to meet you